like shite look at off is that what
Americans do Canadians don't do this
there we go today we're doing Canadian
versus American snack swap we're pretty
much you know crossing the country
crossing these lines and seeing what
snacks are better I'm just really
excited to experience with drink and all
the members of cigars have experience is
that how you see Canada's Drake that's
all hey Degrassi okay are you ready to
try the snacks yeah round one
chips over there this is one of my
all-time favorite chip flavors that like
ketchup chips people love them a lot it
kind of tastes like ketchup but it has
this like nice tangy sour now Funyuns
originally are just onion ring chips now
you're adding the monumental flavor of
flamin hot which is traditionally on hot
cheetos I guess you swish now there you
go smells really nice to Degrassi the
texture taste like puffy Cheetos and
then I don't really taste like a huge
body inflator
mmm it's like a hint of onion and I know
my mouth my mouth is burning
I don't like ketchup they do a good job
making this n to catch up I'll give them
that but I just don't like it tastes
like crunchy ketchup plates I was not
expecting to like these at all but I do
awesome good I'm going back to this hey
if you love some ketchup go invade
Canada and bless yourself with some
ketchup chips around to cookie time this
looks so wholesome like I'm worn a
grandma's house looks like you're gonna
eat I'm waiting for Drake to come out
and like all flannel just then give me
like a like a cup of hot coffee yeah on
a move shirtless boy you decided to me
cookie audio new greatness of its
birthday well these are maple cream
cookies
it's made with a hundred percent real
Canadian maple pure syrup
so definitely Canadian no no no me
posters it smells right ha this smells
like a goes that's what it was for
though my hair yeah I was hoping that it
would be a little stronger on the
birthday cake flavor but it doesn't
taste exactly like a normal Oreo I think
none of the maple syrup it screaming oh
I get a bunch of you mm-hmm it'll be a
problem oh my god anything they're both
winners
yeah just depends on this is what you're
doing yeah if I had to choose I would
choose birthday cake oreo sorry Canada
is converting round 3 candy bars so this
is a teenage um this is a classic
American like candy bar and that's
camera peanuts it's like you go to the
baseball game that's well game and it's
always eating a damn baby all right
this is coffee crisp have you ever seen
this before have you ever had this
before I have no idea what that is
so what you're holding in your hands
this is a chocolate bar that you can
find anywhere in Canada tastes like
coffee that's why it's called coffee
credit the inside is kind of like wafer
II and it's very like light and soft and
fluffy
you got some crispy layers you have some
chocolate layers and then it tastes like
coffee here you go darling thank you
this looks American with like the white
red and blue and it's paid
it's very baseball West mmm-hmm Wow I
actually really like this one it's like
a coffee Twix
I love Reese's Peanut Butter Cup so this
is kind of like an on chocolate version
it's nice the peanuts are kind of like
salty and roasted so it's kind of
balanced as the sweet caramel nicely
okay I think it's like I think it's
crisp I definitely think this is a
chocolate bar for adults I think I would
stick with coffee crisp mainly because
they forgot the chocolate bonus round
stereo we're only trying an American
cereal today because we've kind of gone
through a really long list and decided
that we don't have any cereals in Canada
at least that we can think of that you
guys can't get down here but it's just
American sue because she's never had
cookie crisps Wow yeah interesting
there's no like maple squares no
chocolatey drakes
just sprinkling down the ball they're
like mini chips are all right it's done
oh so good
Wow to be a kid in America I like it's
very sweet mm-hmm as the milk soaks in
we got even better but I like the idea
of having mini cookies at cereal because
cookies taste great when you dip it in
milk just by itself so this is a whole
thing
it works my favourite things were the
birthday cake Oreos definitely those
were a party in my mouth and this which
I can't wait to finish later I think for
me my favorite was the ketchup chips and
of course Orioles are still gonna be my
number one I would have to say my
favorite is the coffee crisps my
favorite is the the painting one yes you
really
it's very subtle it's like not super
sweet and I like how it's salty asleep
[Music]